[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody how's it going happy
Monday
start of another week obviously streams
are still trouble but that doesn't mean
we're gonna stop today if you couldn't
tell by the music we're playing some
animal crossing we just released an
awesome mystery island tour guide so to
speak
thanks to Callie and I am actually gonna
link that in the chat as well if you
guys want to check it out but basically
it's a day we're just gonna good with
mini mystery islands as possible see if
we can get lucky I have not been to a
money Rock Island at all they really
really want to hopefully get someone but
we'll see we're just gonna try to go to
this mini miss around spots wolf all the
farm all everything engine I am I hope
everyone is doing well let me know if
everything sounds and looks ok just our
training on my island which which maybe
could be a good thing
[Music]
anywho what's up chat hey Brandon
welcome back Andrew pyro Christian Jason
Jim toaster pasta vanilla mmm what's up
you guys happy Monday
hope you had a good weekend I obviously
had a weekend full of animal crossing
[Music]
honestly I cannot even put this game
down dad Brandon's in the chat he was
playing the weekend scavenger races my
most favorite thing actually that we did
I dug a bunch of holes and I buried all
these random things stuff that was like
common like a tree branch all the way up
to the gold nuggets and super fun so
yeah I didn't make sure my pockets were
emptied but yeah let me do that first
hello ash welcome how's it going I do
have one ticket I just gotta go make
sure everything is so is a settled and
an order so we can get maximum pocket
space
[Music]
it's basically a game where you just
live a happy life on your island you
farm and you buy stuff I like to burn
fossil before I get them assess it's
really fun though you created a little
village you bring excellent says Animal
Crossing food prizes is favored games
you know what it's pretty much up there
for me as well right now someone in the
chat asked best tip for money so I'm
gonna link you something right now
also gonna be a little Hut we have up on
the website right now
[Music]
I know we have a for you right now here
we go we have a ton of for you guys here
my island usually one extra axe and one
extra shovel is enough to just get all
the resources I usually want out of the
Mystery Island so we will just
[Music]
or animal crossing is your baby is your
favorite yeah so there's that guy I just
have a semi steady source of income all
the time so um you can travel more than
one Island in a day as long as you have
Finnick miles to spend on tickets
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um this sir I have not done the KK
concert yet I haven't gotten there yet
I've kind of been a little obsessive you
have the money tree if you dig up money
from a hole in there it'll grow I didn't
catch jaws Brandon I'm so sad I got a
bunch of hammerhead sharks but no job
but I'm gonna try to hopefully go back
to my friends
[Music]
cool Randall's that is
[Music]
yeah I try to buy this mini eliminate
items
[Music]
[Music]
your brothers will hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
obviously I heard about the
[Music]
[Music]
I feel like I got super lucky I got my
switch literally last one did the island
me this movements here island is like
this invited some TV characters to my
island and they haven't arrived yet so
you have to build some houses I think if
you go to pump it he'll help you like
put lots of land down yeah I try to run
far enough where when I turn I can swipe
the wasp the only issue is like you have
to stop running before you turn or else
if you run and do that and slide Vegas
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and try to get the money island
[Music]
I really want to speed it up I'll just
write it all clean yourself I am trying
to get the last of the reader
achievement I probably won't fish much
unless oh yeah I think I if you keep the
river empty as fish by scaring them away
and still a big shadow response at the
end of the river by the speed okay
[Music]
[Music]
in
I feel like I feel like I always an
easier way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um so you guys get the iron nuggets out
of hitting the rocks is my favorite bug
so far yeah you get a ton of miles
our chat doesn't really
[Music]
each other
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh you can swing right away
I didn't know you could swing right away
usually like my character does like this
shots like emoji reaction and then I
just get scared so I ran a little bit
[Music]
my character I try I try my best to make
a character look maybe there's not many
options but you get close enough
Kristin I'm all right no it's bad all
right I'm approving Ash's fan code hey
Richie I'm uh I'm letting everyone post
their friend codes in here I know I love
peach Island
I love do peaches
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I love the custom design editor is
really a game changer I was like some
other cute outfits too and I'd like from
the interwebs so cute I had to get this
dress I made this pattern based off of
this one that I downloaded but I thought
it was so funny because the one I
downloaded literally gave the character
boobs look cute Oh sexy mama there's
spiders when one is super cute but the
key number three Kyrie that's the one
I'm rocking right now Oh any h3h3 fans I
also have a teddy bear
I love this game so so much
jaren marry Isabel right she deserves it
she deserves the world so they finally
got one other antique item like that in
a balloon so now I'm trying to expand on
that set you know I got to get my happy
home rating up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah although your name changed my
Island tune to the Lost Woods song and
it's so funny because you talk to each
villager they play the tune but like in
different octaves so some of them are
like really low and deep and cranny by
buying like all the special limited
items yeah what a Bob Jones big spinner
I had to buy that vanity you don't
understand I had to buy it before the
stream is over I'm gonna send you guys
my friend cool too and then open up my
eyes
[Music]
so that I can have
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
really really good
honestly I forgot animal crossing has
been taking over my life but I do really
need to go back soon so I could finish
the campaign on nightmare mode yeah
everyone yeah yeah the scavenger hunt
was so fun
well those trees like I played like
three golden nuggets in the scavenger
and found it first try I literally had
like 30 different like bowls that you
can save up and the first one he went to
which is like hidden he got it I was
like that is insane yeah I haven't found
a money Rock Island
[Music]
- but now they're getting the travel
we'll get some mild dose well your
native fruit that's probably one of my
favorite things I like for the fun of my
native true
[Music]
oh I still got all of the nice it
friends to be finding sensitive on that
like you wanna get every single rod
[Music]
oh I did see those like this breezy doom
guy unicorn skin
[Music]
yeah your friends I always tried it from
sweet and then the question jizz cuz
these always give like this is you get
two hundred miles times table for
another four hundred towards the
marathon
[Music]
usually I would come to Mystery Island
chop every tree great every Rock pickup
every we in the ground
[Music]
so level it but we're on a mission we
have to find the money rock island's so
Farnborough for two but it's okay
eventually like if we go enough we have
to find one
[Music]
um I actually haven't tried that if
fruit makes you run faster I know it
just makes you a little more powerful
[Music]
[Music]
I'll see you guys if you don't know what
I'm talking about
today we are trying to get to the money
Rock Island I've just put the link to
our mystery island guide shoutouts to
Cali and yeah I have an idea of what we
could run into trying to see what the
odds are that we would run into any of
those Vincey like an island that has all
pairs which is not my native fruit so
that's useful lots of money bamboo
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mm I have short island open I mean easy
oh sorry who Lama
I read your comment as I was being it
easy has their island open if you guys
want to join him while you're watching
[Music]
I think the first time I went to the
Mystery Island I had an eye
[Music]
got a good feeling
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we have a ton of awesome guides right
now underneath so definitely check those
out we have
- no ton of Awesome inside
[Music]
[Music]
oh snap mondo ding that's a good fun
neck here I have not heard that song
forever so basically my Island they're
all fish from top team levels to spawn a
surgeon guaranteed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we said to talk to you
[Music]
I needed a larger shadow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I haven't done enough
[Music]
thanks guys thank you
[Music]
I've been going and visiting my friends
island right
[Music]
[Applause]
No
[Music]
how do you get clothing after you buy it
um it depends on where you're buying it
from because sometimes sometimes you
have to give you buy it it gets mailed
to your house you don't get it
oh yeah there is a way to alright I'm
gonna get another ticket we're gonna be
back at it again
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you can always tell when you're catching
like a like a special fish because the
vibration goes crazy on controller by
the way this can be my chance to show
off my Museum because I've been Dino
[Music]
good
[Music]
dang I should get my sauces my fossils
assess sometimes donating something
anyway I never know I've been hoarding
them up a bit I try to get them all
assessed at one okay
if you anything like me I'll be like a
ram and do one thing go there get back
and then something else always makes me
stop like I was like re I'm gonna drop
off this fishing go back I'm sorry
my attention span is way too short but I
love it's Daniel
[Music]
[Music]
balloon Grandin if you're still in the
chat my museum has definitely you guys
were here for the scavenger race all
right
you guys have to see magnesium all my
hard work I've done a lot of digging a
walk through
oh and a bellows here I'm missing two
things in this room right now oh this
makes me miss going to museum really
really bad so I'm at least thankful I
have a museum I can go visit on my
island whenever I want
that's probably why I care so much about
getting all the dinosaurs and all the
fish and all the bugs
[Music]
I'm still missing this guy's oh no I got
the week wait let me see yeah oh no I'm
still missing something see that guy's
body this guy's still tall you can't
even see his head without looking yeah
so cool I'm almost done with my t-rex I
just need to find his tail his tails
floating around somewhere all right
there you go yeah yes I just wanted to
show off the museum a little bit we're
making insane progress see I need team
X's tail and then he'll be complete I
love that the camera angle changes to
like a photo worthy angle thank you see
you in here quick but yeah I have a true
love for museums this is like my
favorite fire little game my fish tank
is looking really good too like I'm kind
of curious where um where the sturgeon
is living
[Music]
oh no I went the wrong way um I did time
skip I don't go crazy I mostly do it so
I can well I was doing it so I can
respawn my fossil spots and sell fruit
but I try not to go ahead too much I'll
like go back one day and then go forward
one day just so I can stay on the same
day but like kind of refresh oh there is
the sturgeon so cool he's hanging out
with the Salmons
[Music]
I'm still waiting to see who else is
gonna go into this one all right I swear
this is the last thing and then we're
coming back to the theory mystery islets
I'm sorry
oh that's Museum I've been to IRL that's
a tough question I used to live in New
York City so I went to a lot of museums
there the Museum of Natural History
super nice I actually really liked it
all right back to the Mystery Island
we're out we're out oh yeah fat fish
sorry I gotta show you guys this big old
chunky boy and then we're out sorry
yeah I've been getting a lot of
duplicates soup up like my inventory
nose full of duplicates I have like ten
fossils on the egg to look at the guy on
the top left yeah he's so cute and he's
big and for that like a plate with fins
and he's a real I think all everything
in this game is like a real animal but I
had never seen them
every when it's so funny I was streaming
when I caught him and I flipped out cuz
you know you're used to seeing all these
tiny fish and he's massive the way he
came out of the water I lost it
it was great all the exhilaration of
really catching a fish all right we're
out we're out we're out I've spent
enough time this is my happy place on
the island I can't wait until like you
know can decorate the outside again
maybe if we spent a little time the best
way of earning enough miles try to
complete all the achievements in like
your your nook miles last app like these
achievements and these ones and I also
like try to travel to my friends islands
as much as possible
mystery islands as much as possible
because you get miles for flying also
now I get to sell all these dinos for a
good money
we online to play Animal Crossing but
there are features in the game that you
do like if you want to download designs
I downloaded a bunch of designs like my
dress is the Kingdom Hearts 3 Kyrie
dress which I downloaded I also
downloaded really cool like pathways and
stuff which make everything super super
nice
oh snap playing animal crossing right
now well that's what's that
holy moly mando there describes an Okie
big use that we use it's so cool though
like when you catch it and it comes
flying on the water on like the world's
tiniest fishing rod it's pretty great so
you can download the designs in the able
sisters store or if there's a QR code
you can download the Nintendo online app
and then in the app you can link it with
your account then you can go into you
can select Animal Crossing it'll be an
option like on the home page and then
it'll be like do you want to scan a QR
code so you can either do the QR code or
doing the actual IP in the able sisters
shop so there's two ways to do it
depending on if you have a coder or
Kumar
[Music]
8.2 feet on average dang you go and
change your Island tune and it's like oh
I'm gonna try to sing it and then she's
like I only play my switch docks when
I'm streaming but I have this webcam
tripod and this clamp that came of my
ring light and together they make the
ultimate switch like always like
breaking down
under taking up so I just put it on
tripod put it next to me play when I can
when I can it's looking normal
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I know I've run into
[Music]
ever since I invited you feeling loose
my island whenever I go to Misty Island
turns on Hannah
so fun if you have a plot of land ready
so if you have all those all three of
your houses already occupied associate
villagers you have to go to Tom just get
another plan
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
yeah
but I think it's along the lines of
battle evil character
[Music]
everything
[Music]
[Music]
all right they can be in your town if
they're from the Seri
ji says what are you doing this game I
wanted to get it but I don't know so
basically there's not a major major
storyline like
to join your island and try to get a
famous musician to come and play so
that's like a general storyline but
mostly it's just live in your day-to-day
life building stuff designing stuff you
know buying furniture gifting it to your
friends and your villagers and just like
collecting is this game Morrison if I
can't play every day that's a really
good question actually because
everything is granted based on the
day-to-day saying like is based in real
time so here's the amiibo with this
option you can invite animals to the
campsite using an Animal Crossing
characters Weibo so that's what that
does I don't know I want the microphone
volume sounds a little too quiet
maybe your volumes down because my
volume levels are looking pretty loud
Erina I'll turn it up a little bit but
I'm already self-conscious about being
too loud this games about being in debt
pretty much actually I'm severely in
debt I am 340 thousand bells and a kya
hello happy Monday how's it going I can
run with me yeah yeah yeah keep some
guys done now you can hold down but yeah
I guess it depends now back to the to
your original question about if it's
worth a plate everyday I guess it
depends if not everyday means every
other day you should be fine if you
think you're only gonna have enough time
to play it once every you know week or
two weeks then you might not be able to
do
oh yeah the game ball you might be super
high let me turn on the game volume a
little bit alright let me know how that
sounds you guys
[Music]
but yeah cuz everything is in real-time
you know so if you feel like can only
play like once a week you're gonna
progress very very slowly unless that
one day that you play you're like time
skipping all over the place oh I didn't
die my Nick miles ticket
that's about three o'clock means we have
30 more minutes I'm in the northern
hemisphere but my friend has a southern
hemisphere island that I went fishing on
their Island and they caught all these
sharks and stuff and now I really wish I
got a southern minister and I got all
the cute fish - I found Nemo so yeah
yeah I guess that's a really good
question because it depends on who x
gets let us know if I can call the
police eh whoa whoa if some people I
feel like it's uh you know in certain
situations I think it's okay like if I
worked a job where I couldn't play all
day and I got home real late at night
and I wanted to you know catch things
that live during the day then why not
change time to a date time because then
you're really gonna be missing out I
feel like in those situations that's
where the real time could you know
hinder someone's gameplay unless they
skipped her home
[Music]
[Music]
Thank You Roenick I'm sorry if I
butchered that thanks for tuning in
definitely get some sleep only have a
good one though schuiteman don't judge
cuz on Saturday night I was definitely
up until like 2:30 a.m. playing this I
was spending all of my time creating my
little cherry tree tea garden FBI open
up I heard you're in embezzling bells
[Music]
you know where I want to go yay Kathy
said I never played Animal Crossing
before by I love it
[Music]
here them friends hit up his friends on
the side and be like yo let me know when
you find out can't pin it on one thing
[Music]
in my shop for the roses so this island
earlier I literally took a ton of them I
may do the same thing or at least a few
[Music]
I'm assuming a DCC is talking about the
money tree I put 30,000 cuz I had to put
any more cuz I had heard someone else
put in ninety nine thousand on accidents
but they still got
[Music]
haven't even gotten a gold nugget yet
heartbreaking Nick miles really tap into
the worst parts of my compulsive nature
and then they make you wait through
those like the items that you buy they
like mail it to your house any other
wait till the next day I'm like this is
torture
it's like real life I love online
shopping I hate waiting
I don't know what I'm gonna spend my
gold nuggets on but I've been working
lately
I can't believe a few cold seconds and
my scavenger a site shipping islands of
every sizes
I know man I was looking for villagers
and I would go to an island and it would
be here tracking and I'm just hearing
like hacking down all the trees and
ripping out all the flowers and then you
go and talk to them how many gold
nuggets is it take for the Gundam I even
look I seen him in my nut shop that I
have
our gold nuggets currency then I was
waiting for crafting recipes that use
them you can use the gold and you can
use they're worth ten thousand flowers I
was not expecting that I was expecting
like
[Music]
DCCC the gold trees are not unbreakable
isn't that crazy I was like I don't want
to waste my gold nuggets on those then
if they're not indestructible wanting to
make friends and Animal Crossing will
you help me I'm new to Animal Crossing a
levy you should post your friends over
in the chat and then never fully all the
other animal crossing views in the chat
will send you an invite guys feel free
to post your friend codes in the chat we
gotta spread the Animal Crossing love
we gotta visit each other
[Music]
the robot hero needs 10 gold nuggets and
gold Armour how do you how many golden
nuggets does a gold Armour take she
thought the Godzilla what do you need to
cook to crack him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well I forgot where I put those we'll
just run through my cherry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the stream trust DCC Callie
is definitely cranking out of the guides
and promise you that oh I know my
storage is getting bailey says space are
equal
oh my vanity that I bought you
downloading the best friend out right
now noise I'm just gonna plop this keep
my pockets I'll come back for it later
my storage is full ding I need to
upgrade my house again I'm just so in
debt so much debt crippling debt there's
no interest
[Music]
can someone rave you on your village um
you can open your Island and then people
can join you but there's no like
surprise all right how many islands have
we been to so far for five that was the
fifth one right I've already lost count
I think I think I think this
[Music]
[Music]
oh so you guy get your friend code for
you Mike where they have endless inside
the game I know you can find it from
inside like this switch patch for it if
you go to your profile page and remember
if you could actually find it inside the
game or not you should be able to go to
your home dashboard on your switch on
the top that has your icon in it and
clicking like scroll down alright Orvil
send us somewhere nice money rock
islands don't let me down Oroville hello
what's up Gibby
yeah and I'll even share the love go
visit each other on each other's islands
okay I got a nominative diamond which is
big money so bless good thing we cleared
the pockets Jeff and
we're gonna grab the fruit all right
nice so this is like one of them works
everywhere
I know right Brandon I Tyler moves
faster when you're playing like the
hyperbolic time chamber man I want to
read more guides on how to like force
spawn certain fish because that surgeon
I haven't seen this stream fish everyone
keeps talking about but I'm dying to see
it I 1 million prison for universe if he
couldn't tell my wife beautiful dude
[Music]
so what's funny is you get 10,000 bells
cristela and miles great and rare leave
you ever meet it's like 10,000 from what
you get off the island unless you are
getting some actually for routing don't
sell enough if you develop a truth don't
listen to that horrible
[Music]
Thank You Sharon um Ali I'm also gonna
add you to once the stream is over I'll
grab your coat the more animal crossing
friends better there's also some cool
Lake achievements that
what this game does me and they scramble
I just get in the zone of like farming
have you guys ever played a kingdom for
couplings I guess I wish a mammal
growling every single day
[Music]
pinkey berry definitely drop that
friendzone drop it like it's hot always
looking for friends
is there a max amount of people like
that that's a good question I just
grabbed my foot last week also like my
own personal one so I don't know all the
ins and outs but nowhere near what a
maximum the gold axe took you two hours
oh my goodness you just like Flint a
billion trees and take your flimsy onyx
is like constantly I saw like a mini
[Music]
I'll just let them come naturally if the
gold axe is indestructible I would be
[Music]
[Music]
crying the will it's a limit is 300
friends
nice I know I need someone in the
southern hemisphere
I have your friends the better
[Music]
all right we up think we have time for
one more try at the money Rock Island
hello happy Monday we ready
thanks locomotion I feel like I have
like officially the name we're like
average struggle listening to my own
voice
and like here two seconds of my own way
so I'm like but a lot of my friends are
that too so I think you can get exotic
flowers it's just all about your ing I'm
gonna paste again a link to our mystery
island guy that has some more info on
that stuff oh you got one Rock Island
last night mucho jealous maybe friends
if you basically have different country
and different language settings I'm not
sure actually like I'm not sure if what
you type and stuff will come through to
me in your language or in my language
that's a good question I guess I've
never really tried that so I'm not sure
[Music]
yeah anybody who puts your friend coat
in also to go back after the stream and
add all of you guys so feel free to drop
those coats
give me them digits your friend code not
boundaries please dude please
[Music]
[Music]
swag accounts gonna deactivated oh no oh
no I think Mayan god got to you because
I'm looking at the tab and it says
sign-in listen Lisa hello welcome to the
stream I'm so sorry really you know I'm
still going but being close to me in the
stream make me sweet sweet bells up
these pears I just scoured from the
islands Thank You Jessica
pick up rain I know Oh Lisa will
definitely drop that code and I'll add
you I would be your friend and hey
anybody else we got Thanos oh my god who
did it who snapped us out of existence
I need no last island of the stream
let's hope for the best
money Rock Island money
alright we're gonna see me somewhere
nice money after all the Nick miles I've
invested into this establishment
that I will farm all the bamboo I'll
break all the rocks but I'll see the
farming of bamboo
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the jam on this
[Music]
[Music]
oh okay I got another one
Oh riperoni
with my life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I have a slide here that has my accounts
on there
[Music]
I knew and I knew it
so seabass all right you guys that is
gonna be the end of the stream today but
thank you guys so much for tuning in
much appreciated I tried to get the
money or like a limpet no such luck
today I will keep trying and if I do get
one I'm gonna you already know I would
take a picture of you post it on my
Twitter your only it's gonna be late
finally finally got one anyways I'm
gonna add all of you guys every one of
you that put your friend code in the
chat I'm gonna go back to the chat and
add everybody so feel free to put your
codes in and I will see you guys in the
animal pressing super soon don't forget
even though we're all working from home
we're still bringing you that hot juicy
content we've got a ton of content
Animal Crossing related and other on our
YouTube and our website right now so be
sure to check that out and of course
every single weekday at 2 p.m. Pacific
time we're alive
right caret so come on back come hang
out we're gonna be playing a lot of
awesome stuff this week as gifts already
know like time cooking on the way and
we're here for it
we're hope hoping you will be here for
it too so come on back thank you guys so
much for being awesome and always tuning
in and supporting us so much
[Music]
you